[Music]
black marivan snatch offers an
experience like no other with multiple
branching paths scenes and endings that
offer an episode that can last up to
five hours whilst we pretty much covered
all of the endings and scenes within the
show what about the ones that didn't
make it well throughout this video I'll
be breaking down all of the scenes and
endings that got left on the cutting
room floor there will of course be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about any of the endings
that I highly suggest that you turn off
now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to the first major delete ending
comes when you get the option to either
bury or cut up Stefan's father's body
viewers may have thought that the scene
couldn't have gotten any more twisted
however in a recent interview with Radio
Times Charlie Brooker stated that
there's a version of that where he's
whistling happily to himself where it's
like the second or third time you've
done it
he's like whistling happily and we
didn't get a chance to put that in
apparently this was triggered when he
had played through the scene a couple of
times with the third time of being
Stephane submitting to it very joyfully
having done it multiple times already
creator Annabelle Jones stated that at
that point he's embraced the fact that
he's being told what to do and it gives
him that detachment the two also said
that this one even further down the line
with the option to urinate on Stefan's
father's grave coming up should they
pursue the scene multiple times
another scene that Bricker was sad had
to be cut in relation to the body scene
was revealed in his interview with
huffington post upon cutting up the body
Colin or Tucker arrived and discovered
you in the middle of the act
Brooke has said we changed the order of
something and if he chopped at the body
sometimes Colin or Tucker would come and
discover you covered in blood and then
he had the choice to confront them then
and there on the doorstep apparently
there was also an option that came
midway in the show that allowed viewers
to watch the fan watching something
Rooker claims there's a bit West a fan
gets a VHS tape and watches a
documentary and I wanted early on to do
a bit where you get the choice of two
videotapes and one is essential for the
story and the other is just like
film that is taped off the telly and you
can watch the whole thing literally just
put it on and you could watch a whole
film from beginning to end but at any
time you could press a button to stop it
overall I think that these would have
made for some pretty amazing moments but
I can definitely see why they were cut
by Netflix and the creators obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
missing scenes and if you have any
better ones be sure to leave them in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video make sure you like it and check
out my breakdown of what happens when
you pick up the family photograph twice
which will be linked at the end this is
the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]